Sub-agents are specialized assistants
that Claude can delegate tasks to.
Each sub-agent runs in its own
conversation contacts window with a
custom system prompt that you define.
When finished, it returns a summary to
the main thread while all the
intermediate work stays isolated.
One of the main advantages of sub-agents
is that they help manage context window
usage.
When you chat with Claude Code, you're
adding context to the main context
window. Every tool call and its results
get stored in this main context window.
And so, when Claude uses a sub-agent, a
separate window starts. The sub-agent
receives two inputs, a custom system
prompt from your configuration file, and
a task description written by the parent
or parent agent based on what you ask
for.
The sub-agent then works autonomously.
When it reads files, edits files, or
uses tools, none of these will appear in
the main conversation. Just a summary is
returned back.
The entire sub-agent conversation then
gets completely discarded.
Consider a task like investigating how
the payment system works in an
unfamiliar code base.
Maybe you're trying to use Claude Code
to figure out which service handles
refunds.
Well, without a sub-agent, Claude might
read 15 files, run several searches, and
trace through multiple function calls.
All of that context fills your context
window, even if you only needed one
single fact, which service handles
refunds.
With a sub-agent, you get the answer
without the journey. The sub-agent
explores, discovers the answer, and
returns a focused summary, keeping your
main context clean.
But, the main window loses visibility
into how the sub-agent reaches its
conclusions and what it discovered along
the way.
Claude Code includes several built-in
sub-agents that you can use immediately,
like the general-purpose sub-agent, used
for multi-step tasks that require both
exploration and action. The explore
sub-agent, used for fast searching of
code bases.
The plan sub-agent, used during plan
mode for research and analysis of your
code base before presenting a plan.
And you can also create your own
sub-agents with custom system prompts
and tool access.
Sub-agents like Claude Code break work
into focused pieces, keep your main
context window clean, and bring back
just what you need, whether you're using
the built-in ones or creating your own.
They're a practical way to get more out
of longer Claude Code sessions.